you and my son have had uh some words
before on the internet he's someone who
used to be affiliated with the game back
in the day right um i mean he went on a
tour too right right right i didn't know
if he was ever black wall street
officials no he went on a tour but uh
you know he's somebody who's obviously
no disrespect my son is
i'm not gonna say was my man he's still
my man it was just getting a little
weird because we've always done our
debates right i was gonna say it seems
like it's a
at least a semi-respectful disagreement
at least everybody's getting hurt
i've seen [ __ ] last night and he put up
yeah i saw what he put up last night and
i i think my son's like a great leader
like you know as far as you know
everything that's been going on i mean
just always you can look for my song for
like direction as far as like if you
want to know i mean that's what he
turned himself into he's kind of like
this like martin luther king type um
revolutionary type dude which is kind of
confusing because like yo listen if you
that stop talking my street [ __ ]
my sign and like that's my man i didn't
see my sign by ourselves all love like
you know these people that's in new york
got to tell you they didn't hurt me and
my sign orchestrating [ __ ] over the
phone that's my man like i don't want to
see nothing happen to him i don't got in
my heart to do nothing to him but on the
flip side my side i had nothing to say
when you was running around with vlad we
all knew
uh you know rick ross never said nothing
either [ __ ] suing rick ross lawsuits
criminal cases and file and [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying cause rick ross
then whooped on vlad ass
talk some street [ __ ] you run around
with vlad but you know why you was
running around with vlad because vlad
was giving you your experience platform
your platform which is business i
understood that was business
understood that you wasn't running
around with vlad saying [ __ ] this vlad
tv a nut [ __ ] would ever come with you
wasn't doing that you were utilizing
that platform because vlad is a big
plastic huge platform and you were doing
your rap thing or whatever it is you was
doing and i was working for you right i
didn't say hey my son
and we talked oh i got long phone
history with my son
text messages for years right hey my son
on some real street [ __ ]
what you doing with vlad
you know he doing that to rick ross
a street [ __ ]
it was business
but i don't know i think maybe he runs
out of things to talk about and if he
runs out of things to talk about by all
means there's a brother he can utilize
my name to bring some publicity to him i
ain't mad at that it's entertainment i
ain't tripping no i mean that's that's
that's a yeah i'm not very mature way of
looking at it i'm not tripping okay we
talked before the camera's rolling and
i'm not going to use anything all my
people let it be known yeah my son and
my book it's not my enemy
everybody that loved me that i just
moved for me without saying nothing i
don't want nobody ever to approach my
son in a threatening way or question him
about anything that got to do with wag
100 that's between me and my sign
period you know what i'm saying period
some real [ __ ]